right now you have a small number of
liberal elites relatively small number
of liberal elites
who make most of the decisions and we
don't really have very much say about it
and if we raise any problems with it
they'll probably be spying on us like
they are on tucker carlson
and the american people of all shades of
all
sexes of all geographies they are
pushing back
against this kind of thing they're
pushing back against critical race
theory
right that is now sort of the lightning
rod
because it is the the expression of
these insane vile
racial ideologies that tell
americans tell white americans and
anyone who agrees with any conservatives
that they are vile so black people who
agree with conservatives hispanic people
agree
tell tell them they are vile vicious
racist that this country is terrible
there the ideology being pushed in these
schools is the ideology of nike you're
going to make more nikes america's a
terrible rotten place and we got to
overcome it we got to hate ourselves
and we got to suck up to china this is
the kind of stuff you know now they're
trying to deny they're saying
the people who are pushing all of these
various critical studies you know
blackness studies whiteness studies
critical race theory
all of these guys they're they're not
really saying
that whites are terrible and whiteness
is evil and all whites are racist
they are here's hebron kennedy ibram
kenny is the most famous one of these
race hustlers probably in the country
today
here he is on cbs news calling all
whites racist i mean as robin
you know talked about it it is critical
for for white people for people uh
in general to stop denying their
their racist ideas to stop denying
the ways in which policies have
benefited them to stop denying
their racism and to realize that
actually the heartbeat of racism itself
is denial and the sound of that
heartbeat is
i'm not racist this is the climate
change of racial politics by which i
mean
climate change it's it's defining
quality
is that it is unfalsifiable any
phenomenon can be used and interpreted
to justify climate change or to
to be attributed to climate change it
gets colder climate change warmer
climate change stays the same climate
change
this is why it's not a very good
scientific theory because you you can't
disprove it well it's the same thing
with this insane racial
stuff what ibram kennedy is saying is if
white people admit that they're racist
they're racist if white people deny that
they're racist
that's even further proof that they're
racist this is
called begging the question this is what
happens when you assume your own
conclusion you begin with the premise as
hebrew candy does
that all white people are racist
therefore if you admit it okay good
therefore if you deny it yup there you
go
conclusion all white people are racist
it's not not a very good argument
one of the many reasons that sort of
things should not be taken seriously but
that is what is being taught and i think
ordinary americans of all races are
looking at this and saying
no that's stupid and it's evil
and it's destroying our country and we
don't want our kids being poisoned with
these idiotic ramblings of a con artist
like ibram kendi or robin deangelo
and by the way i say this as a civil
rights icon
okay i don't know if you saw it i don't
know if you were perusing amazon
but right now my book speechless
controlling words controlling minds is
the number one
book in civil rights and liberties
uh right now it is beating at number two
and number three and number four is
ibrahim kennedy and robin d'angelo but
number one
is michael knowles and i'm just very
pleased that amazon is finally
acknowledging my role
as the preeminent civil rights leader in
the country
that's good and so i tell you i give you
permission
as people who care about civil rights
do not listen to ibram kennedy and robin
d'angelo they're the number two and
number three recognized civil rights
leaders in the country but i am number
one
and so i'm telling you that they are
idiots and they are poisoning your
children and our country
you should not i hate to be so mean
about it but it's a
it's a crisis it's a real threat and so
no one should pay attention
to their nonsensical ramblings
hold up glad you like that video go
check out the whole episode it's right
here it's called pay no attention to the
man behind the curtain you can also get
it on apple podcast spotify stitcher
google play all the places
for your audio podcast and most
importantly of all
after you like and subscribe and leave
comment you can go order my book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds
it's the number one book in civil rights
right now i am the number one civil
rights leader in the country
go check it out i'll see you next time